the Four Knights of the Apocalypse are
the heroes of the seven deadly sins
sequel they include Percival a boy with
verdant wing-like hair who is also the
Knight of death he has a very rare Magic
called hope and he speaks the language
of demons for some reason Lancelot is a
mysterious boy with no fixed appearance
he is the Knight of War and the son of
bond and Elaine so he is half human and
half fairy Tristan is the boy with both
Holiness and evil in his eyes the Knight
of pestilence and the son of meliodas
and Elizabeth so he is part demon part
goddess and also part human because this
incarnation of Elizabeth is human Gawain
is the Knight with gold colored magic
and she is the Knight of famine she is
also the only female member of the group
and she possesses Sunshine escanor's
former power subscribe to anime uproar
right now